AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME--
MALE MAN.
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
MAGIC MIKE XXL HITS THEATER THIS
WEEK WITH A MEATY THWAP, WHICH
IS GREAT... IT'S GREAT NEWS FOR
FANS AND HUNKS AND THEIR RELATED
BUNS.
A QUICK PERUSAL OF THE FILM'S
IMDB PAGE REVEALS THE
AFOREMENTIONED HUNKS HAVE SOME
TRULY AMAZING STRIPPER NAMES
LIKE TARZAN, SLICK WILLY, AND
BIG DICK RICHIE.
(LAUGHTER)
OR CHRIS HARDWICK.
AS GREAT AS... AS GREAT AS THESE
ARE, I THINK WE CAN DO BETTER,
SO I WANT YOU TO COME UP WITH AS
MANY MALE STRIPPER NAMES AS YOU
CAN IN 60 SECONDS.
AND BEGIN.
PETE HOLMES.
>> HANNIBAL.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
PETE AGAIN.
>> HANNIBAL BURESS.
>> HARDWICK (LAUGHING): POINTS.
POINTS.
BRIDGET.
>> HUGE GRANT.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
PETE.
>> CHANNING TAINT-YUM.
>> HARDWICK (LAUGHING): POINTS.
POINTS.
YOU SAID THAT SO ACADEMICALLY.
BRIDGET.
>> DAD?
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
HANNIBAL.
>> MARTIN LUTHER KING
DING-A-LING.
>> HARDWICK: YES, POINTS.
HANNIBAL.
>> MAGIC MIKE HUCKABEE.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
PETE.
LOU BMEUP.
(AUDIENCE GROANS)
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, LOU BMEUP.
LUBE ME... OKAY, GOT YOU.
>> DON'T GROAN, THAT'S GREAT.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
HANNIBAL.
FIVE-DOLLAR FOOTLONG.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS.